[Music]
[Applause]
today I have a very very special guest
for you all he's a two-time NPC winner
with Canterbury he's a six-time Super
Rugby winner with the Crusaders he's a
2015 Rugby World Cup winner that was of
course with the New Zealand under 20s
and now of course he is a very very good
all black on top of all that he's a very
humble man very funny he is a deep
thinker and has an extremely big chest
if you don't know who I'm talking about
by now then you do not know rugby he is
one of the great Lads Jack Goodhue
welcome mate oh thanks Jimmy what an
intro
mate yeah I think it was the big chest
that would have given it away
fortunately my bench press isn't as big
as what the chest would is that not no
it's not disappointing is that why guys
always tell you to get on the bench yes
well I'm always on the Pinterest yeah
um I don't need to tell me but yeah some
some boys just have a really good bench
press and I try really hard but I feel
like I should have one but I would have
thought you would have been one 60 to
180. no see You'd think yeah that's what
people expect in it
constant disappointment how about 150.
oh okay not too bad same as me
true
that's that's so disappointing for you
because your your chest is like five
times the size of mine what can you no I
can't do it now but that wasn't right
yeah could you yeah yeah right wow yeah
Wingers wait outside deceptive yeah I
don't know if a wing yeah but sorry I
know you requested some um psychedelics
to sort of ease your way into this
podcast I do have some pure sport uh
mushrooms which probably I don't know
might do just as well but well I only
requested them because you said oh let's
get into some flow so I was assuming oh
what do we what has he got in store for
us yeah but you know it's obviously
disappointed not that I'm into that
stuff but I thought even was thinking
wow he loves
yeah I don't want people to think that
but I thought well if ever there was a
safe environment to try some this is it
from someone this would be it wow
obviously no it's not gonna happen no
sorry I didn't um I didn't even know
where you get them from to be honest
yeah I can't help you I do know some
people there's probably some people on
the team that would know oh true but I'm
not have you ever have you ever tried it
because I know you're not yours so
you're in very anti-drug man aren't yet
but like myself haven't smoking a
cigarette never done any drugs yeah yeah
I've never smoked a cigarette I've never
done any weed that I am from Northland
so I've probably done some secondhand
weed in my time
whole life has been around it
um no I'm not into drugs um I guess when
I was younger it was kind of more
educated that it's like pretty scary
stuff obviously you can get like
addicted to it I need to get a little
bit older obviously you know some people
kind of smoke a bit more occasionally
and stuff
but I guess I'm really big on
controlling your mind and
um it's kind of what the Bible says
around like alcohol as well it's like
it's not that alcohol's bad but it's
just when you have too much and then it
starts to distort your decision making
and stuff so that's probably where I sat
as far as any kind of drugs it's all
good until it starts messing with your
mind and you start making bad decisions
and I think that's probably the way I
approach things and you are someone who
is always looking for a little
professional Edge I feel like you've
you've sort of been the Trailblazer for
professionalism and rugby in terms of
some of the some of the things that you
do outside the game for the extra little
bit of recovery extra little bit of Edge
and I feel like I
something like that you're on to you're
onto something going forward what is it
what's the next big thing for you
can yeah so there's always been a
mindset of Mind of like if I'm going to
do something I want to do it the
absolute best
um yeah my parents always vouched for I
was very kind of uh serious kind of kid
as far as
um competitiveness and wanting to be the
best at everything I did
uh as far as recovery and
professionalism goes I feel like I've
gotten a lot better at that probably
since my injuries oh yeah so I've kind
of taken that more seriously
uh not that I didn't take it seriously
before it's just like okay I need to
probably do this better if I want to be
able to continue to play rugby and feel
good because yeah after a couple of
major uh knee surgeries it's hard for
the body to feel as it was but yeah then
what's the next big thing I don't know I
think it's just
yeah I didn't have anything
um you don't want to give away your
secrets
but there's a few things like what if
what are things you're doing at the
moment that you swear by I know you're a
big sauna man yeah ice baths breathing
all of that stuff is it yeah
um oh that's that's great that makes you
feel good you know the cold showers in
the morning if you're into that
um saunas I'll probably do that two
three times a week uh there's nothing
like special about like oh no secret
like recipe for how to how long to Saun
or anything but I think just going to a
point where you feel it makes you drink
plenty of water electrolytes if you want
while you're soldering ice as well the
contrast all the ice
but for me probably lately I've just
been thinking I've just been really
nailing my diet because I'm probably
like the heaviest I've been in like the
strongest I've been for a long time and
it's probably just been like hammering
the the protein in a more regular basis
has really been working for me so it's
kind of yeah that's the oldest kind of
trick in the book you know eating eating
well so that's what I've been doing and
still no fizzy drink I think we spoke
about this the other night but you're on
a fizzy drink ban but you're still there
no oh yeah it's gone yeah yeah I'm not
as strong-minded as you sometimes just
sitting there on the table and yeah I
couldn't say no but I still try and
discipline myself you don't buy it I
don't buy it no no
[Laughter]
different guys
yeah disappointed you have a nice story
no it's okay you'll you'll get there but
you mentioned your injuries and you have
had a pretty rough run of injuries
um talk me through sort of the first one
you got it's mainly been your knees
hasn't it
yeah well my first major injury was uh
in 2015 during the NBC of Canterbury it
was like second round against counties
Manukau when I did my ACL
and that was pretty
I guess uh a pretty kind of clean uh
rehab it was back out there in 2016
feeling really good and you know had a
few kind of niggles here and there after
hamstrings and stuff but mostly a pretty
good run until 2021 where I did my other
knee and there was a lot more uh serious
I had that ACL PCL MCL which took about
a whole year to recover so it actually
you know the normal ACL graph that would
take the patellar Tinder now of your own
knee and use it as a new ACL and then
the PC I was actually and they call it
allograft which is actually
um a dead person's Achilles tendon geez
is what they put in for my PCL because
it's a lot thicker tendon and peace out
the thicker ligament so they need to
replace that that's in there now that's
in there now wow do you know whose it
was I don't know but it came from
America oh wow that's pretty pretty
crazy what they can do but yeah grateful
that yeah that was able for to happen
for me
um and so that recovered that's I guess
a lot more serious as far as it's a bit
sore still now like it takes a bit of
time was a lot more serious injury and
then as I was kind of coming back from
that one
my old ACL knee which happened in 2015
which actually happened after a long
period of time out there like a
traumatic kind of injury it's just you
know the cartilage begins to wear away
that he's not the same
so there's a bit of cartilage kind of
catching so I need to go in for another
surgery last year and that one's feeling
pretty good now
um so I think we're just like
accumulation of knee injuries the body
was just shutting the ticket going again
um hopefully I feel like I turned a
corner
around like March April this year where
I was like okay I can back-to-back
trainings you can get going again you
know play a game be a little bit sore
but I'm not sore for you know a week or
two I can kind of I'm not on the
anti-inflammatories anymore get it going
so it's exciting for me
but obviously the body's changed and how
hard was that for you to deal with
mentally like going through
those big knee reconstructions or not
reconstructions but the injuries
especially the ACL PCL mcl1 how hard was
that for you to go through mentally
I think incredibly frustrating the first
one in 2021 was like I'm out for a year
um but I I had a long contract so I knew
I was going to be financially safe and
had time to rehab so it wasn't too bad
but then on the back of that when my
right one side of hurting again and then
realizing I had to go in for another
surgery I was uh you know it was like
times running out and not how I wanted
things to pan out you know I was Keen to
play more rugby I felt like I had more
to give but you really start to doubt
yourself it's like am I gonna be able to
play rugby again yeah I feel terrible
like I feel like I'll go for a run and
then they'll be aching for days yeah
didn't know if I was going to be able to
you know get around this
um so those mental struggles start to
come in you start to think
what am I going to do after regular
that's what I started to think I was
like I'm gonna get a building
apprenticeship or is my body even gonna
be able to handle doing booting
um yeah but I feel like the good thing
is I am
uh around that corner a little bit I
don't know how much longer I've got left
like realistically though
yeah
Anything could happen as far as I'm not
as
possibly resilient as what I was before
but I feel like I'm getting there so I'm
still hoping for a lot more rugby in the
future because you're still young hey
you're deceptively young 27
uh deceptively young do I look old
no you've just got a maturity about you
it's wise beyond your ears okay good
recovery but I thought you're older than
me yeah turning turning 28 very soon
okay so yeah still still well late 20s
you're in your Prime really you thought
all of the news fires maturity guys yeah
yeah
oh sure anyway I am always Keen to hear
your journey from the start and I know
you grew up in Northland what I didn't
know until recently was that
Josh is your brother or twin brother I
knew it was your brother I didn't know
you guys were twins yeah that's pretty
crazy and five other siblings or four
other siblings including yourself yeah
so there's five of us yeah yeah and what
was yeah what was your bringing like in
the big up in the north
yeah it was good it's funny a lot of
people don't
um realize that Josh was actually my
twin brother they realize we're brothers
yeah we're Twins and they're very
surprised obviously we look very
different he's a giant you know six foot
six everyone thinks he's older but no
we're we're Twins and we're the youngest
of
the family I've got um two older
brothers and one older sister
my older brother
uh he played a little bit of
professional rugby for cam or was it
camera Cameron Legend you heard about it
yeah I know it's funny he's a he's a
good man he's very kind of charismatic
and social as well and um I had a few
teachers at Meadow grammar school where
all the boys
ordered and um then I had a teacher who
went down to otago University because
that's where Cameron studies as well and
and they were like oh good you what's
your brother cam
I'm like oh yeah do you know him like ah
just heard of him
so that was kind of Cameron's um
reputation
uh but yeah we grew up on a dairy farm
out there and uh yeah my sister was kind
of uh she was awesome but she struggled
with how much how obsessed I guess our
family was a rugby you know it's always
on telly on Friday Saturday night and
then Dad would coach dad coach all of us
um for our time so he was heavily
involved he kind of was the life of our
Rugby Club United
you know how to Coca-Cola
yeah small town in the Bay of islands so
he kept going keep the things going and
he'd probably helped you know hundreds
of kids kind of find Rugby to kind of on
a Saturday morning and really worse the
lifeline of that club so he's still
someone involved now but um Step
as of lately and um it was an awesome
upbring on the farm there and then went
to boarding school at Meadow Grandma
um played with first 15 rugby there we
we had a good team but we didn't win any
kind of titles I guess it was just very
competitive you know Auckland grammar
and Saint Kent's kind of dominated
the years I was playing first of Dean
were you good at that age like were you
was this a scholarship that took you
there or did you just go down there as
just a regular kid
um or you you were Gangnam yeah
I was my twin brother was definitely
I I guess we're both good players but my
twin brother was kind of he caught the
eyes of probably the mags um oh yeah
teachers and Scouts if you will because
of his height was he massive back then
yeah yeah it was very tall uh so he was
we we both went there on half
scholarships but the joke was Josh had
the full song
but I won't get one free yeah it was a
good deal for me regardless
um
and it was Josh then made um New Zealand
security schools oh yeah so you missed
out so I missed out I did yeah on um
yeah the secret schools and the
Barbarian team at the time yeah uh so
yeah so when I came down to Canterbury I
was gonna I'd applied for a scholarship
at Lincoln University and I guess I
don't really think Kennedy Knew Too Much
About Me
wasn't in the academy at all uh but
straight after
the Megs sevens competition we were
planning you know the Condors in New
Zealand a single school competition yeah
I went and played for Northland sevens
and I made that team
and then we did a right like you know
regionals and Nationals and then
just to how it worked out I think there
was like one player who Gordon kitchens
wanted in this New Zealand Sevens team
but wasn't eligible or something oh yeah
so I got a late call and he's like oh do
you want to you know have like a wider
scholarship contract yeah which wasn't
much at the time but when you first year
out of school you're like oh this is
exciting yeah
first year out of school all right so I
knew I was coming down the Canterbury I
was like but yeah definitely want to do
that and then it was I'm Sam Dixon and
Mark Jackman down here so I got
alongside them and started training with
them and went to a few camps and
didn't make any of the um Stevens like
uh plane squads that yeah but it was
some good hard yeah
by the end of it I just wanted didn't
even want to make the blue team just
wanted to go home I was I honestly
didn't know I still don't know how those
guys played so many years yeah under
such hard training because I was young
and pretty you know resilient back then
yeah by the end of the week my body was
imagine doing it now
mate because there's no GPS's back then
Alias no no load management you were
just oh yeah I think they had GPS's
birth oh I think Massachusetts coming
after me oh we're there as well I think
I think touch just
um had his own way of doing things yeah
just probably say the least right so
yeah he was in control and he and
obviously a hugely successful coach as
well so he was doing something right but
other thing a lot of boys probably
couldn't handle the load and struggle a
bit and but those that good you know
they did well
but um yeah I didn't make a uh Stevens
playing Squad that year but it was still
awesome to be involved in that
environment and I learned a lot and
trained work ethic and all those things
um
as I was outside playing for Lincoln
University as well and I think I was
doing all right there so they invited me
to join the academy oh yeah but I just
kind of stuck with the sevens
and then went on and made Canterbury
that year anyway and yeah it was all
kind of happened quite quickly from not
making secondary schools I think I just
had a bit of a gross burden yeah got a
bit of speed I probably was like the
slowest back in the first 15 rugby team
um in my year 13 and then I don't know I
just kind of picked up a bit of speed
you had to get speed I remember bodies
saying how he got speed but how did you
get speed
oh man I suppose having like a more
regular gym session probably helped but
I think it was just come with time and
age as well you know sometimes workout a
little bit quicker one day
that's often it happens isn't it man I
wish I got that that's cool
but you must have been slow if you're
saying you're fast now
and you mentioned you missed out on New
Zealand schools and The Barbarians your
brother made it how hard was that for
you because obviously people always
compare brothers and I could imagine
twins has probably double the comparison
so what was it like when you missed out
your brother made it how hard was that
for you
yeah I'm not too bad I I used to get uh
super nervous around like first of Dean
I I'd say I found that probably like the
hardest rugby like me really and I think
it was just at the age where I probably
couldn't handle it as well as
um I do now so for him to make it I mean
not it was just I was very happy for him
yeah and me and my dad got to go to
Sydney to watch him play so it was like
it was perfect oh true so you know yeah
you obviously you don't have much
confidence in your ability at that age
no and you I didn't I don't think I
deserved to make it yeah then so okay
um I'd have a different mindset about it
now yeah I'd want to play you know but
it just come with kind of my own mental
development and I guess I was kind of
just back then but afraid to kind of
like make mistakes with stuff up yes get
super nervous before my first 15 games
like
the night before kind of would just be
like don't don't want to stuff off me
yeah my teammates my friend of my school
I guess that kind of changed
um with like probably two things when I
became a Christian and was able to
actually put the rugby in perspective
and then there was the other
life-changing book was um I read was a
mindset right like
talks about the fixed in growth mindset
and I think a lot of people get taught
that now
but actually if you're afraid of making
mistakes you've got to fix mindset
you're not actually prepared to get
better because you need to make mistakes
yeah to get better
um and that's the growth mindset and I
just hadn't heard of that concept so
to actually understand it to read that
book I love that book yeah how old were
you then just so
um the physio here at uh Crusaders gave
it to me when I was um
so he after had my first ACL in June
2014 he gave me that and I was like this
is a life-changing wow sounds great for
me and I gave it to my twin brother
thinking oh yeah he'll really love it as
well it's super boring he doesn't even
finish it yeah I was like reading all
the examples like growth mindset on
business yeah sure read that like growth
mindset of how to bring up kids this is
awesome so he didn't share that kind of
obviously it was hugely
um
to everything I've obviously been
looking at life the wrong way like no
one's I realize now I'm trying to be
perfect
but no one's perfect you've got to make
mistakes to be better yeah 100 and you
mentioned your religion so you weren't
born into a religious family is that is
that just you who's gone down that road
yes yeah when I was um 16.
I um there was an evangelist which is
just a Christian Pastor he preaches the
word a bit more and he came over and to
Auckland and I went along with him they
invited me and went along to with some
mate sit here and speaking I was like oh
this is
at first I was like I don't know if I
believe in this but it's interesting and
I was like I owe it to myself to look
into this in case it's true so I did a
bit of research into Christianity and
then looked at the science because you
obviously Evolution has breached quite a
bit like school and stuff so you think
oh you know the Earth and people just
evolved
and long story short as I said this is
more likely true than not true and all
the research that I did so from there I
was like I'm I think I'm gonna you know
believe in this stuff because it I think
I'm not going to believe something just
because I want to believe it I'm going
to believe it because it's true and then
my faith just kind of developed from
there true so how did you where did
where did you go to from there like
what's the next step
for becoming a Christian yeah yeah well
everyone's kind of Journey is different
but from there I just started going to
church and learning more about the Bible
so as a 16 year old you'd go to a church
on a Sunday by yourself oh no would the
friends that invited me oh okay so you
had mates who are already Christians
yeah yeah well she was at the boarding
hostel so oh yeah it was actually the
the main house master
um he was a Christian and his son was a
couple years older yeah so we got a long
well and he was kind of floating around
The Boarding House we'd live in the
house close by yeah so we would go go
along together and
um yeah hugely different to what
obviously I grow up not going to church
so it was a big change for me yeah as I
said it you know I was like well from
what I've kind of looked at the books
that I've read like I think this is true
so I'm going to look into this
probably took about a year before I was
like yeah I actually believe in this I
kind of just thought I'm not gonna just
dismiss it because I don't want to
believe it I'm gonna try and work out
for this is true and yeah so next to go
to church and learn more about it and
meet some people ask heaps of questions
and I feel like I know a lot about it
now I feel like
if anyone has any questions around
if they you know why they don't believe
or about this or that I feel like I can
have a conversation with everyone about
most topics and how's it sort of seen in
the rugby circles is it is there a big
Christian
community in the rugby circles or how do
you feel about it in the rugby scene
yeah it's it's pretty accepted like
there is a lot of faith in the rugby
circles
um a lot of people are on different kind
of Journeys or might have like slightly
different beliefs here and there but
it's mostly pretty accepted like I've
never had an issue with you know people
give you a hard time about anything and
rugby you know it's just better but but
the whole like respect of it is there so
people are good oh that's good and then
just go back to Canterbury so you made
the New Zealand Sevens you'd made
yourself you found yourself into the
Canterbury NPC side
um was that the year that you picked up
your first injury or did you play some
games that first year uh I played some
games at first year so 2014 was my first
year 2014 and um so I was first year out
of school and then 2015 after New
Zealand of the 20s came back for
Canterbury in the second game there and
I got my ACL injury so you made you
missed out New Zealand schools but you
made New Zealand Tweenies
had you and you'd read the book so you
by then or did you feel comfortable when
you're in that New Zealand under 20s
time I think I just developed a little
bit more I'd matured a little bit then
already so I kind of and had a stronger
face so those obviously reading that
book in my fake I feel like helped me
develop mentally yeah a lot more so I
hadn't read that book yet oh okay and
then it was after under 20s and I got
the injury that I read that book and I
was like oh this is this is a really
good book yeah
really eat it I still recommend it to
people Josh should finish it he's
listening
um I think I lend it to Joe Moody last
but that was a few years ago and he lost
it oh but I think I bought a new coffee
so if anyone here who knows me would
like a copy I have one okay read it
because it would be good for you so then
when you have that first injury do you
feel like yeah how do you feel about
that one you obviously such a young age
you're Keen to be on the international
scene or the you know get your name out
there early injury how did you feel
uh yeah obviously disappointed but at
the same time I felt like I'd had a good
run even to that point like I'd already
signed the
um Crusaders contract
is that true he's out of school
yeah I was pretty fortunate to have
already signed it so I signed it after
20. so it's literally like
maybe like a month after I signed that
Crusaders contract um I had my first
major injury so
I felt I guess that I was in a way
a little bit naive in my belief that
I'll just get it right and continue on
the path that I was kind of going
because things are just going really
good and yeah I guess at the same time I
wasn't too because I didn't make
secondary schools my goal
after school
if I could play for Northland yeah that
would be a successful rugby career for
me yeah there was actually all I wanted
to do
um so I guess it was the mixture of like
things are going good nothing to worry
about and I'd already kind of achieved
my goals I actually wasn't too
disappointed you were exceeding all
goals low expectations
and then fast forward you do come back
for um Cannery the following years at
the year you win the win the NPC
Yeah well yeah we lost to Tasman
obviously in 2014. yeah I don't know if
you remember that I do remember it do
you Trafalgar Park yeah yeah yeah so
semi-finals
um and then they lost to taranaki yeah I
don't know who good that yeah they were
very good
yeah shooting
um
so yeah I think we won 2015 in 2016 for
Canterbury it was funny actually so I
didn't actually play in any of those
finals I did my hamstring like 2016 see
me final oh
but this is how it is I've can't really
complain about the run I've had as far
as yeah winning goes
um yeah and then after 2016 I was like
I'm really Keen to hit back up and
represent Northland now because that was
a dream of mine I just
I just kept growing up in a small town
um in Northland as well there's a lot of
passion and pride in the Northland
Jersey and my Dad loved Norton as well
so that really rubbed up on um
as kids so
my twin brother was already up there
playing for Northland I was Keen to go
up there and join them
went up there and played um 2017 season
for Northland from there made the
um in the year tour Squad after that so
I was called about a play for Norfolk
yeah
um enjoy that and then make the all
blade off the back of the playing
football
so were you did you know you're in the
frame for the All Blacks how did you
how'd you know you'd made the All Blacks
well
um I had been invited into the 2017
Lions tour Camp oh yeah I can't remember
what midfielder had an injury but um
someone was coming back from injury
because it was Ryan karate Sonny bull
four midfielders but Steve Hanson wanted
me to come in I was sitting there for
the whole tour about a month up in
Auckland
um and then so getting developed there
so I kind of that was a surprise to be
involved in that but I guess I kind of
knew that I was close
oh man during that time
um so Ryan Crotty does hamstring oh yeah
the first game and I was like okay I'm
here for injury cover and there's an
injury there I obviously knew there's
still Nani sunny and Anton yeah
I was like all right now he's now on the
bench for game two and then 100 and then
Sunny ball gets red card game two you
know sitting there in the stand thinking
oh my gosh
they better win there because I don't
want to be playing in the deciding game
three what about the growth mindset
I learned to read the book again
obviously
obviously imagine the first time
um yeah Cameron you're starting to feel
the weight of like what if I actually
playing this game through
so they lose their game it's pretty hard
to win get a red card
and then um yeah it's obviously Tuesday
morning and then malachite
shows up and Steve Hansen chilled hits
means what we're gonna play Milk I
figured though but if you did this
before
and in all honesty
it was a bit of a relief
I don't want to sound like a coward yeah
I was pretty nervous thinking if I've
got to go out there and play the decider
for the lion Soul which was just a huge
amount of pressure in my mind
I would have I think I would look back
at that now if I do get the chance to
play it would have been like that would
have been awesome yeah against the Lions
when I lose that would have been
a huge compliment accomplishment would
have been a great challenge
um but the fact that I didn't it's fine
too I completely understand you know
you backed out
Steve didn't know that no no he could
hear it in your voice he thought it was
a confident young kid but in the inside
so fickito wasn't even in the squad no
oh true he just came in and took that oh
crazy so when when did you get there
debut was it the following year it was
against France wasn't it
oh well
that was my test day boo
um but I've kind of got a funny story as
far as actually getting over there for
the India tour
um so we played I played for Northland
in 2017 and obviously as I mentioned
made the all black India tour Squad off
the back of that
and I think I had already been oh no no
I've got the story
so we're playing a semi-final in
Wellington against Wellington and
Wellington a really good
um this is when they had the Premiership
Championship oh yeah Wellington should
have been the Premiership they probably
had the best team out of everyone
there was one before we went down to
Wellington to play to play them and we
got beaten and I was feeling
a little bit crooked that week
um I didn't really train too much
um but went down and played and I was
about terrible to be honest
um but played anyway
and then
we were having our you know inde-season
Doom rake up and it was actually at our
flat uh oh yeah so it was me my twin
brother and a good Maid of man uh Josh
Larson who was also playing for Norfolk
at the time
and I just usually you know I really
enjoy the kind of India do have a few
drinks and really get to know your
teammates even more but I just felt
terrible like couldn't get going
and because it was at a flat I say
I actually had to get out of there I
felt that bad
um so this is in whangarei so I went to
grandma and Grandad's house it was you
know 10 minutes down the road luckily
and Grandma was still up so I said
Grandma I'm not I'm not feeling too good
do you mind if I stay here
um and so luckily that yeah he was awake
and she's you could stay there but what
I didn't tell her was that I was getting
croaking I was actually starting to
feel in my like testicles like they were
starting to feel like not right they
weren't they weren't feeling right and
actually showed one of my teammates he
was like
oh mate it happens to me all the time
what you got you just got blue balls
mate you just gotta you've got a release
one out
that was like a heart told me that and
um I made a school man of mine I'm like
mate that's the last thing I feel like
doing right now
so I've got this kind of problem going
on and then kind of overnight they're
definitely like swelled up yeah but more
one of them was swelling up
and so
there I am wake up Grandma Grandad's
house
um
having breakfast with them and I start
to get these messages come through
oh big congratulations well done Jack
proud of you kind of thing yeah and I've
forgotten that the All Blacks were
getting named that morning says
distracted yeah well when they would
they would man you begin the best news
ever which it was but that doesn't
matter if you've got swollen testicles
that's the only thing on your mind
so there I am having a cup of tea and
breakfast with Grandma and Granddad
um getting named in the All Blacks but
the only thing I can think about is what
the heck is going on
and so this is a public holiday so
um my GP
um they're not working at the moment so
I just got to get up to Mom and Dad so I
drive an hour north up home and they
thought well you probably should go to
the hospital and get that checked out I
go to the hospital and there's a female
doctor there and
she said well it's not obviously ideal
but she said all right well we'll have a
look see what you got in Tuesdays
I don't worry you're the healthiest
person I've seen today all you need to
do is drink some water I'm like I don't
know how many people you have coming in
here it's falling difficult
offensive item you know I'm just like
this is ridiculous so
I'll just dismiss that advice and
you know go home and haven't told the
All Blacks what's going on yet or
anything I think they're flying out like
maybe in over a week's time or something
but
get to the GP the next day and he's
still not sure what's going on
um but he does a few blood tests and
I have the day before I'm Supply poster
flyer on the end in year two of the All
Blacks
I've told all blacks doctor by now but I
get confirmed that I've got months
months yeah which was going around at
that stage and a lot of people don't
realize
is that some guys get the swollen
testicles where most people get like
swollen glands around their throat oh
yeah my testicles bumps in your
testicles
drink your water
just dehydrated
oh wow yeah so
I
obviously I don't know if I was going to
play against the barbarians
um
that uh yeah in the India tour but
everyone else who was his first year in
the All Blacks did play in that game so
I assumed I would have but I missed out
on that game because I got the months
luckily I still went over
and played The Fringe 15.
um which is a few weeks later so I went
over a bit later
um
but I was about six kilos lighter than
my normal plain white about terrible
yeah the game went all right we just won
I got yellow carded oh great yellow as
well I think I think Richie broke his
hand
um with the shambles that we saw one hey
that is that is some yarn so the mumps
mumps cost you your first test cap but
then you played against the French
barbarians yeah got a yellow card and
lift the dream you weren't officially an
all-black by then though because it
wasn't counted as a test cat is that
right
you get your test kit later that year
against France next year next year 2018
where France came over to tour New
Zealand and I'm playing the third test
and what was that like no no where she
was leading up to that one no no the
testicles were fine body weight was back
drunk in your water
yeah yeah that was
it was it was good to play a test and
we've always had already done the job on
the first two games so
to go out there and play free and to
play my all black status and have the
family down there was cool if it was a
decider would just I've wanted to play I
wanted I told you I wanted to play the
Lions game
but I felt like there's more pressure on
the line
and we haven't even spoken about your
Crusaders time because man six Titles
since you've started
um You've Won it every year pretty much
since you've been there first year being
2017. was that the that was the first
time I played I was contracted for 2016.
2017 the brumbies yeah yeah and then
talk me through that yeah was that the
year that you won the final in South
Africa yeah yeah as um yeah a lot of
cool images
oh that's right were you calling that
what do you think when he put that up
that truck Oh I thought it was an
absolute Hail Mary I thought it was a
mistake brain explosion I'd kind of been
like roving around them like like we
need to have a run here the Ford's gone
about 14 15 phases deeper and like a
little
back and forth um yeah they weren't
going anywhere yeah they were super
tired it was only a matter of time
before
someone's gonna get over the ball and
we're going to get turned over and I
would say hey yeah Mitchell we've got to
have a run here we've got to have a
crack it's too far yeah I think it's too
far to have a drop goal
but he just sits in the pocket and I
swear
I chase it in it just gone over the
Barlow I won't even be surprised if it's
scraped the crossbar there amazing too
amazing memories and I think it was like
moments like that he also nailed a
penalty against the Reds
over in Brisbane
um
I think it was it before or after that
but it was a couple of moments like that
said to scoring in the corner against
the Highlanders that year to win the
game
um and another in another game is
Highlanders
moments like that just made that season
we almost had that belief that we're
going to win the close ones after that
yeah and did you believe you'd do it
over in South Africa beat the Lions who
were running hot that year weren't they
I I thought we were going to do it I I I
remember thinking on the bus ride there
that we're going to be Super Rugby
Champions yeah in a matter of hours I
thought we had the team to do it
oh we had some awesome players can read
met Todd
John tafua
yeah it was a good team and then did you
still feel that way with 10 minutes to
go
against the lines and they're just
coming at us they were coming home hot
weren't they they were although we had a
red card as well but yeah
I mean maybe if I didn't get um quicker
stuff didn't get a
yellow card I've red card it might have
been a different different game yeah
they were good in that last Rampage they
wanted it but we just held on our
defense was good and we scrambled well
yeah and I heard you on the celebrations
after that night all time you're in your
best form of your career I was just
doing what I got told
as I said earlier you know I like to
keep my wits about me when I drink
alcohol so I did do that I stuck to my
values but
yeah you're alluding to the point where
Matt Todd had me drinking wine early in
the morning yeah
so was Matt Todd how did you and Matt
Todd gets it was he like your Mentor or
um who was who was in control of you on
your debut year
uh I probably got around Ryan karate a
lot oh yeah but um I think met Todd
really enjoyed those kind of in the
season dudes yeah yeah he's he really
was a funny guy and a lot of Life at the
party
and so I just remember we'd kind of been
out at a bar or something and everyone
was was home by that point it was early
in the morning and then our phone and
the hotel room started ringing and it's
met Tom and he says look Jay you know
all the fishes that come into my room
you don't want to be the only one who
doesn't show up so you better get here I
I don't think I'd been to sleep
so there I hear me make my way up to
Matt Todd's room in the only one who
shows up and he's pouring me a glass of
red wine to enjoy it about 6 a.m 7 A.M
in the morning
uh that's living absolute living
you know good times and then obviously
the next five titles any
any memories or Seasons that stand out
for you there games
um I mean every every year special
I think the first one obviously holds
the most memories
um
but last year going up to you and park
and yeah it was
probably my next favorite if I'm gonna
pick one
I think just doing it away from home
again
um I guess kind of not been favorites
were you as confident on the bus going
to that game that you're gonna be
Champions or was there a bit more doubt
than that one
oh It's Kind of a Funny place with my
mind as far as I definitely believed we
could do it I knew I thought it was
going to be very very difficult for us
to do it though
I thought the blues are awesome team but
I knew also that my right knee wasn't
right oh yeah
about that whole kind of seasonal
especially the final as part of it I was
struggling um
so I was almost like I was actually
almost thinking is it the right thing
for me to play oh well because I don't
know if I'm gonna
be the best midfielder out there in my
team is it better for Braden in or to
come in and start because I was in a lot
of pain and I
ended up getting surgery a few months
later but I thought I should have got it
earlier
um so that's kind of where my mind was
at so I was a little bit distracted but
once I got through the warm-up and I was
like
I feel like once I start playing I'll be
alright and throughout the whole game
you know just just Managed IT uh yeah it
was
I guess for me as a milestone of
you know push pushing through that I
don't think you should push through all
pain but I think when the time's right
you've just gotta get the mindset right
and play
um
and I thought Richard [__] was just
outstanding with his kicking game
um listen well Jordan were great with
the running game and it just
one of the most amazing complete
performances
I've ever been a part of yeah I'm glad
you played because you were on fire too
saw me and all yeah I think I just did
my bet as far as catching pass and make
a few tackles a few big carries from
memory
it was that probably makes it memorable
as far as
yes how good Iran was on their day
and then talk to me about your All
Blacks obviously you made your day boo
any
2015 not 2015 2019 Rugby World Cup
what was that like hmm
um
that was yeah that was that was amazing
to be a part of I feel like in 2018 I
started playing some really good rugby
as far as um I feel like just body
develop everything felt good
timing felt good felt strong
um
so that form kind of carried on into
um but obviously huge pressure huge
expectation to go out there is an all
back in the World Cup even more so than
the lion Series so how are you feeling
well I'd read the book by this reread it
reminds me if I killed it
um yeah I was I I yeah I feel like I
I was obviously a huge amount of
pressure but
I don't know I feel like I was
even though it was only my you know
second year in the All Blacks
yeah don't get me wrong I felt a lot of
pressure but
it was also just a cool opportunity
um
I thought I kind of changed my mindset
of like you know you know what if we win
what if we do this
obviously to lose against England in the
semi-finals they played just a really
good game
um did you play that one
yeah I played that one starting started
with um that's right I've got subbed
Sunny came on
um later on in the second half
yeah they were just good hit over the
ball disrupted our line out fellow we
couldn't get anything going so that's a
yeah a little back of that and it's hard
to believe that it will cup you again
this year yeah
and yeah hopefully I'll be part of again
and getting up try and get another crack
at it but they're just so hard to win
obviously
we thought England were good on the
semi-final and then they couldn't do it
against Africa in the final year it just
shows how tough it is to win the
competition yeah and like you say this
year is going to be so so tough there's
so many teams who can win I feel like
International Rugby is more competitive
than ever I think so I think Six Nations
awesome this year you know Scotland
looking really good
I can be you know some good teams on
their day yeah South Africa good at the
pressure game and putting out High balls
and
defensively put you under pressure
um you know England if they get it right
their best team out there
really good players really good fought
back and obviously what island are doing
France yeah yeah you're right it's very
competitive at the moment and you
mentioned your Ambitions to still be
there have you heard from anyone in the
All Blacks set up how does that work
um
Ian Foster you know talked to me after I
pulled my groin earlier this year and he
said look man I know you're having a
tough run but
just get back out there and and do your
best
um and so you know it was nice to hear a
call from him obviously I've
to make that team you go to play good
and you know it's they're going to take
the best team that's out there
um that's available so
yeah I don't know I have no idea where I
sit at the moment as far as the rankings
of the midfielders
but it's just been nice to kind of feel
like I've turned a bit of a corner
earlier this year and be playing I think
if I don't make it and I feel like
um healthy I'm actually all right with
that it's kind of just that
disappointment of being injured and not
getting a chance not getting a crack at
it you know to not make it would I'd be
fine with this yeah just want to give
myself the opportunity to
yeah mate surely mate you like you said
you've been playing some unreal footy
um your body's looking good your knees
looking a lot smoother than it was at
the start of the year and mate
how did I look out there really what
were you thinking we were like oh my God
I was thinking this looks like me yeah
uh well those are some days where you
just couldn't get gone yeah just like it
was so sore yeah I know that we really
want to sort of push through it but
yours has just come I don't know what
you've done you've done that's what I
was asking at the start around your
recovery treatments what what have you
found that's fixed it into such a good
knee now because I need some
obviously we've got awesome physios I
think one thing like I remember earlier
this year where I had the lowest weight
on the leg extension you know oh yeah
and with my right knee I couldn't lift
that up with my right knee oh wow it was
too sore
in one of the areas I just how am I
gonna get this right but it was I think
I ended up going to a band with a Physio
and we just worked through that and then
I could do the first play and I could do
the second play and it's not pushing
through too much pain but you might just
need a little bit just to ask the
question of the knee yeah and just I
feel like just getting the strength
around the knee joint it's probably been
the thing again it's not no secret it's
just
just getting strong and healthy again
and now you can lift all the plaques
no that's not true probably probably
still below probably what the average
rugby player can do but it gets you
through yeah so what what's your plans
obviously World Cup dependent but what's
what's your plans for the next
you know you're only 27 soon to be 28
you've got you know seven to ten years
left
yeah
I don't know what the plan is at the
moment
um yeah I'm not signed anywhere next
year
my wife and I are looking at a few
options
um who knows when this podcast gets
released I don't know any releases
podcast there might be something out
there but
we're looking at both options as far as
here and overseas
um love love playing for the Crusaders
um and for the for the few games I did
get for the All Blacks that was amazing
experience it was a childhood dream come
true but another dream of mine is also
to
have an adventure and learn another
language and with it now or later
oh yeah I'm not sure but
it's given me a lot of Hope to know they
can still play rugby I don't know how
much longer but
I feel like yeah we're talking about
quite a few kind of learned about what
my body needs and how to get back out
there and what my week looks like so I'm
feeling good at the moment so hopefully
can play a few more years so you've
narrowed that down to Japan or France
with the language barriers
deciphering the riddle
one more clue
short seasons in Japan yeah they're long
seasons in France yeah
um
but I could imagine you over in France
atmospheres
oh interesting
but hopefully you're here
for a I like to work a bit more with you
yeah I feel like we're just getting
started
yeah you you've been really good this
year as far as looking after the back so
oh right I can't wait to see you always
never were you in town Robin take this
team before to work with Rob yeah I
don't know much about him did you work
with him
um NPC level no no I didn't but I've
heard good things yeah from some of the
people that do know I'm in this
environment that is a lot of fun oh
perfect yeah and met Todd obviously
he might be sending me to the room with
red wine Stoner don't answer the phone 6
am in the morning if he's calling
you sort of mentioned it before around
like planning for Life After rugby when
you head your knee
um recoveries so have you got much plans
for Life After over were you thinking
um and that sort of space
um one thing I've been thinking about
lately is
maybe a bit of a volunteer work with St
John would be a good place to start I
kind of
like the idea of being able to help
people but also feel like rugby has
taught me a lot about how to work under
pressure
and there's a lot of pressure as you can
imagine yeah being some sort of like
paramedic or something I don't know if
I'll be able to handle it sometimes when
I go to get a vaccine is that what you
studied so I wouldn't even talk about
your study at Lincoln oh no I studied um
agriculture at least oh okay
I came wherever so you'd look to get
into
um studying to become a paramedic or
yeah I just wanna I think you just kind
of just turn it up
um I started the process uh
a couple years ago after my first um
knee injury but I couldn't quite get
everything together before I kind of
returned to players but because of
covert and stuff
um
so they kind of teach years you go you
obviously wouldn't be yeah you know
you'd be getting help along the way or
you wouldn't be going to like the major
incidents if you have obviously a lot of
research and stuff but
yeah as I was saying to kind of deal
with that pressure
of the moment if there's been a car
accident maybe absolutely crazy I don't
know if I could deal with it to be
honest when I get a vaccine I still look
away from the needle so
what am I thinking thinking that I'd be
any good at that oh I think it'd be good
like if I had a car crashed there's one
person I'd want to see turn up in an
ambulance Jack could you 100
I want him to do this
um poor people if I show up I'm sorry if
I show up in you and I'm the Saint John
it's cool though I would not have packed
that bat that is cool I like that yeah
it's something that's been on my mind
for a while
John's
um calling you up all over the country
wanting to take you through the process
yeah well they were they were awesome
when I started to go through the process
and it's kind of
that was all me disappointing on my
behalf there just couldn't finish it but
obviously it's just the Rugby schedule
where it's hard to yeah do these courses
sometimes which are required
um but yeah it's good to know that you
know I've met a few people and how that
would now look yeah if I did choose to
go into after rugby yeah and you
mentioned it doing it voluntary how long
would you have to do it voluntary before
you get paid because obviously
I know you've made a lot of money in
your rugby career but to live off a
voluntary job for the rest of your life
would be tough oh that would be tough
yeah if you're doing it voluntary you'd
probably only do it maybe once once a
week or so oh yeah yeah
um and then I think it's really up to
you if you want to pursue it more and
get those hours up I'm really
speculating it's probably something from
St John's
you definitely don't have what to say
I think if you want to push three for a
paid role I imagine you obviously do the
hours and there's a few probably
interviews to go through to see if
you're up for it yeah
would you ever get into coaching because
I mean I know how smart your rugby brain
is especially on the defensive side of
the game would you ever look to go down
there or not really your thing
um
it's funny when early in my career I
thought definitely not as I kind of get
a little bit older I think I see
how cool it is to
enable players or people to do awesome
things on the field as far as like
character development if you help them
learn a new skill
become a better player that is quite
fulfilling job
and also just the excitement of you know
having your team and trying to get them
to be another team you know just a
simple process of winning is is really
cool
um I don't think I'll get into it
straight away yeah I think it'll be cool
to
step away from rugby take a breath do
something else do something John's and
then move into coaching and then you
could turn up to a game do this and
John's and coaching double dip that
would be good paid for both yeah because
I don't know I could run be an extra
coach and run on and do messages yeah
for the players it could actually be a
real strategic move yeah right oh
there's something in there I like that
looking forward to hearing more about
that one day but we have gone to our
Instagram for some questions and
Jack Goodhue being there
very very popular man I didn't realize
how popular your mullet was either
millions of questions came in for them
not not Millions hundreds of questions
came in for the Mallet so we'll get
through a few of these
um
first one why didn't you keep your
magnificent Mallet tell me through this
tell me the story of there well it's
interesting even just cutting the mullet
and there was a few boys in the after
the 2018 India tour were no cutting and
mallets throughout that touring us I
think Leon Squire and Brody metallic
probably the main instigators at the
time I said can I join the mullet crew
you know just wanting to kind of be a
part of it and be a part of the chat and
they said you know sure you can cut in
the moment Jack so so I did
and I keep about the whole summer
thinking that we would reunite
um in January for like the promos with
all blacks like meet up and do a bit of
like Fitness testing and we'll have our
mullets and see how far they grew and
then only for me to shop and I was the
only one with them oh wow so they had
talked to each other saying I'm gonna
cut my mullet off and so they all did
but no one told me
and so call it pride or whatever I was
like nah I'm Gonna Keep My Mallet yeah
you know and it's still pretty short at
that stage so it definitely wasn't a
thing and then throughout the 2019 tour
219 season
and just kind of grew and kind of people
took hold of it and they really liked it
they did it was just a bit of fun really
um and then egg became a bit of a thing
and people loved it people asked about
it all the time
um
and then I can't actually remember if it
was yeah it was 20. I think after 2020
season just had done its time really
yeah so you just cut it just cut it was
it for charity because it was a lot of a
lot of publicity around it wasn't it was
it it was even the news headline that
night
Jack good Hughes mallet's gone or like
it was big news in New Zealand wasn't it
I don't know if it's a headline about it
but we I did like a a charity thing or
bald Angels uh to Cherrydale Northland
that just look after
um yeah feed whanau out there and yeah
and so rather than shaving it for a
charity which is what where bald Angels
actually came from oh yeah
uh I said a good idea will be a bit of
fun with it and people could text and
vote in you know shave or save oh yeah
so
apparently it's overwhelming amount
people said save the mullet
and um so I saved it and then we ended
up just dying it pink ah and the funny
thing is my
well I was Sophie and I were going to
get married at the end of 2019 so I was
actually gonna
um shave it off then but
we actually couldn't get the winning
organized in times I postponed it and
then we thought
because of Christians we didn't want to
work too much longer to get married and
the testicles are still still exploding
and so we thought when's a good time to
get married and I'd already
um organized to do this charity thing I
think it was end of February
in 2020 but the date that worked out
really well to get married was like the
week beforehand oh so my wife is amazing
and she actually really loved the Mallet
and she would actually like me to bring
back the mullet oh um
but yeah I probably would have cut it
off for the winning
and are you looking to bring it back is
that is that what you were hunting there
or no well
the reason a lot of people are like oh
you know why don't you bring bring back
the mullet it's almost it was a bit of a
distraction a lot more people recognized
me when I had the mullet it was it was
like going down the street yeah wow it
was a significant change in my life when
I cut it off
no one now knows who you are no one
knows who I am who's that guy he wasn't
a Crusader's top
even when I wear my Crusader uniform and
down people don't recognize it now
wow that's fascinating
okay next one um tips to grow an
Immaculate mullet
oh
well I don't think I did anything
special
but I have heard that collagen helps
um direct do how do you do is that a
pill it's a pal yeah internal okay
supplement that powder pills there's a
lot of ways to take collagen apparently
um so I would recommend that otherwise
my wife would complain if I didn't
shampoo oh yeah enough so that's
probably something that you'd want to
make sure you master that or your
brusher did you brush it a bit no I
never brushed it I did permit though for
that charity it was a pink and purple oh
wow if you've ever got had a perm before
it smells terrible
because that chemical oh yeah yeah oh
well yeah I didn't know that until
obviously it happened yes learn
something new every day thanks for
teaching me that okay next one tell the
story of traveling to the wrong country
in an off-season travels there's
stealing from John Gardner it is it is
this is true did you go to the wrong
country yeah but it wasn't my fault what
do you mean it's not your fault how does
this happen it's like Home Alone
hey
yes I don't know how I'll tell you how
it happened but I still don't know how
Evan okay
um
I thought after the 2016
season
played for yeah he had paid for um
Cannon Brown I thought it'd be amazing
to just go do a little tour somewhere
you know by myself and see the world
because it's kind of what I was into
yeah
and so I went to a travel agency and I
said I looked at a few kind of
um kind of not they they're called G
Adventures so it's kind of like a
Kentucky but you know at least drinking
and more kind of Adventure kind of thing
yeah but you made a kind of a random
crew over there
and go and do it right
um and so I wanted to go to like Central
America which was like Guatemala and
Honduras and stuff
and I said this is where I want to go in
the travel agency no worries I'll take
care of all of that
and so she booked all my flight and
everything
and so where we had to meet was a place
called Antigua now
Antigua the one I wanted to go to was in
Guatemala but you had to fly to
Guatemala City and then drive to Antigua
to meet them
what the travel agent didn't know and I
also didn't was that there's an Antigua
in the Caribbean island oh so I thought
here I am traveling to Antigua
I get on this why and I'm thinking I'm
getting pretty close I'm like
he was looking pretty small
flow into the wrong country
this is what happened and they quickly
get me back on the same flight now I've
got to fly back to Miami oh stay a night
in Miami and then the next day I fly to
Guatemala City but when I by the time I
get there they've already crushed the
border to Honduras so
the traveling agent has organized a taxi
who's going to drive me from that border
all the way to catch up with this crew
so we drive like five hours all right
see driver does I'm paying like 200
Euros yeah like pretty cheap in
comparison
and we catch up this crew and I'm just
yeah I'm like go travel by that by
yourself they say a little the worst
possible start to this experience but
we're okay but let's that's how it
happens we rattled to handle those
situations how do you handle those
situations super radar by myself I think
I was on that flight back to Miami I was
I was like kind of nervous shaking kind
of thing like what is going on I don't
understand in Miami unpaid for now
now that if I did that and I'm playing
now you've read the book
now I've read the books I handle any
situation
that is a good story I like that one
okay
uh here's your cooking skills improved
were you still serving raw chicken for
dinner
it's yeah I don't know how I got the
timing so wrong with that chicken I
thought it was done the funny thing was
I had so much pride that I continued to
eat the chicken trying to convince
myself no friend that's fine let's cook
and I'm gonna keep on going I was like
being silly just put this chicken back
in the oven good thing is neither of us
got sick
but it was real real raw it was very raw
it was definitely raw I like maybe just
eaten it
next one what do you fancy a club team
World Cup and who do you think would win
that
yeah apparently happening hey 20 28 or
2027 yeah yeah we just got told that in
2026 they're going to have like a
smaller smaller version and then yeah
I think it's cool I don't know how the
logistics of how it's all going to be
managed yeah
I already feel like there's a already a
lot of rugby that gets played yeah
Horrors
something's got to give yeah something's
gotta go for sure
so I don't know how you manage player
welfare and stuff but I mean it'd be
awesome to see you
you know Crusaders go up against the
saracens who do you think
what you get so
it's so hard to compare
I do know that they're amazing teams and
it's hard to
know just how good the defense is up
there when you're not you're not playing
a team that you've played yeah yeah run
against them but I think would
hold back the Crusaders to to win
Crusaders with Jack Goodhue or Lara's
shower with Jack good here
[Laughter]
good morning
yeah you know it's going to be
interesting
um very hard to compare you're right
okay next one
um
what's his thoughts on social media as
an athlete
I think um social media is is fine to
the point of if you want to learn
information or or yeah and keep up to
date with your friends but I'm very
cautious of social media
more for the effect of how it's
effective
people find it and how addictive that
they're trying to make it
the whole idea is to try and keep people
on your phone for as long as possible
and they've got very smart people trying
to make that happen
so I think it's actually very harmful
for a lot of
teenagers especially but I also think
it's wasting a lot of people's time in
adulthood I would actually like to see
him
you know stricter laws on it
particularly for for young kids and
teenagers because I think mental health
wise it's not good as far as comparing
you're comparing how you look you're
comparing Lifestyles you know you can be
feeling good
and you're seeing someone
um having an awesome holiday or you're
seeing
some of your friends catching up and
you're not there or you're like how come
I didn't get invited into this or
something and you're like that's
can put you in a bad mood yeah and I
think it's actually harmful so
yeah I'd like to see a bit more done so
how do you control yours uh you
mentioned you're very cautious how do
you control your time or social media I
delete the app oh you delete it wow so
um it's on my phone at the moment
there's no Facebook there's no Instagram
uh there's no Snapchat as well I think
it's actually it's probably not too bad
um because you probably only got inmates
on there anyway
uh so that's all delete it and probably
like once today or download Instagram
have a quick look once a day once a day
oh you'll download and then delete it
again delete it again okay because just
stops me from clicking on it yeah
mindlessly sure so that way I've got
this big time I want to do something
that I feel is productive and that's
what works for me I like that
um I think if you haven't done that
before and you want to try and reduce
the amount of time you spend on social
media apps I would recommend you try
that and what time would you download it
I'll just win it if I feel like now is a
good time to check it I will
probably try and not do it like before
bed I feel like it's a bad time to look
at it just when I got a moment and I'm
probably end up spending like maybe like
10 minutes on there
um and then delete it like how quick
Wi-Fi is yeah these days like you can
download it very quickly but it just
stops you from yeah
it just helps you be in the moment yeah
wave the yeah your team you're sitting
at the dinner table it's so much better
just to
that's what I always try and sit with
you at dinner and stuff because I know
you have good conversation you're not
going to be on your phone
do you do that that's very nice Jim I
don't know if you're joking man I'm
gonna take this the truth that is the
truth it's always the truth and that's
interesting it's a good point around
social media like that okay what's it
like pairing with Renee Ranger in the
Midfield Tony farz greatest ever
Midfield convo
yeah Rena Ranger is such a character and
obviously
um he was an amazing player wasn't he
like he just could was orez
wow
that is amazing that is still fine for
Norfolk I know he should have come a
couple of tough injuries as well yeah
yeah he's obviously not as good as what
he used to be but the fact that he's
still playing rugby and King compete out
there and play NPC not sure how old he
is now
but it was awesome to play with them and
then uh 2017 yeah when I first paired
with him yeah he was you can still light
it up he could wind back the clock and
and do you know some awesome things on
the field so one of the hardest guys to
attack I reckon he was in his prime like
you say he was so hard to attack her
yeah
he played with my brother and it was
like 2011 that sort of like Cam and all
right that was probably when did he make
the All Blacks was probably 2011. yeah
yeah I'm guessing
yeah obviously he was playing his um
absolutely it's rugby there 2011 man
that's a long time ago hey when you
actually work it out yeah
okay good stuff okay uh what did you
think your greatest asset as a rugby
player is or what do you think your
greatest asset as a rugby player is and
how did you get it
um
I would have to probably say defensively
um just yeah just enjoy making tackles
it's probably my strength and where I
got that from was definitely
on the front lawn tackling my brothers
oh yeah I think when you're on the
smallest of us four brothers
so having to go out there and basically
tackle my twin brother and then taking
my older brother who
we'd often played 2V1 League that was
Axel so here's the one that really
toughened me and Josh up sure
so he's had a huge impact on our rugby
careers and then my old brother Cameron
was which is really good because he was
we would play 2v2 touch but how was yeah
in the summer on a lawn
um on the farm so
it would be me and axel versus Josh and
Cameron and
you know they'll just just getting those
rips and catching pass
um competing against your brothers who
are you know faster than you as well
that's where really I feel like hone my
skill as far as just getting numbers in
yeah and in years I said 2V1 League
having to tackle my older brother who
was four years older than me to be brave
in those situations you still got it he
used to
when he was kind of giving me and Josh a
hard time how he justified it was I
think my dad loves to tell the story is
what's wrong with it Dad
therefore I'm eight four plus four
equals eight it's a fair contest
and he saw it as fair game yeah fair
enough and then I probably got tip weird
Josh
um just got so big so quickly and
we probably got to the age of 12 or 13.
yeah and actually was 16 17 and between
the two of us it would probably
be a good contest yeah it's like the
perfect recipe for a professional rugby
player I feel Dairy Farmer brother of
three or two older brothers playing in
the backyard a lot of footy it's like
the perfect recipe similar to the
Barrett's similar to the Barrett similar
to so many guys I've had on
I think
fortunately being younger siblings and I
do mean this a lot oh a lot to my older
brothers and we're just being there and
toughening us up
just competing against them you
definitely I think there's a lot of
actually science behind the younger
siblings because they have to compete
um more likely becoming professional
sports stars solely for that reason just
fortune and yeah to have
yeah a family is super close
um
yeah I love them a lot yes I owe a lot
to them Josh and I both do yeah we're
our rugby careers yeah I see it with my
boys like the youngest has to be the
toughest because or else you don't
survive you just get there's no choice
you've got no choice
uh hopefully he turns out as good as you
do on the footy field okay two more
questions
is your favorite yoga move still suck
bro better chick after ya
we used to do yoga me Tim Bateman Ryan
karate and Brent Hall you know on a day
off to try and look after the body and
we had no idea what these but what the
yoga poses were called so we had a great
time like just I had you find the soup
cup Butternut you know
yeah that's all that is okay that's a
good one tell me you sent that one
answer shout out to me okay last
question ask everyone just wanted to oh
there we go roll the ad
the business is going good Tim okay
[Music]
um last one ask everyone this one best
piece of advice for a Waterland listener
what if what does Jack go to you got for
us
well if I could recommend a book
let me guess
I think you know
as far as what I've learned playing
rugby
even in all those pressure moments
um you know when it actually comes down
to what I had thought about like making
mistakes and we all make mistakes
all we can ever do in any situation is
only our best like when you've been told
you've got to go and execute this move
you can practice it train it as much as
you can
really got no idea if you're going to
execute it or not yeah you you prepare
your best
um
but we all make mistakes so we can go
out there and actually do your best I'm
gonna I'm gonna try my best to make this
tackle but I could miss that I'm gonna
try my best to you know find my Winger
on this pass but
at the end of the day it could go
anywhere but all I'm going to do is just
go out there and do my best and that
mindset has probably
serious saved me well and probably
calmed me down a lot
in all situations right what a way to
finish I I do listening to you here talk
there I feel like you should write a
book
of genuinely there's so much knowledge
out there such a deep thinker like I
said in the intro I'm glad you deliver
because I said funny guy deep thinker
you've you've nailed it all off on this
podcast I was a bit I'm always about
hesitant to call someone funny before
the podcast but now I think yeah that
was a lot of people now yeah and you
delivered like you came up with some
funny stuff you're you're a deep thinker
yeah
it was the only funny story I've got
best story ever but I do appreciate you
giving up your your time on your day off
to come and sit on what ahead and share
your story you're an incredible lad I'm
looking forward to hearing where this
next chapter of yours goes whether it is
hopefully here or or France or Japan
wherever you choose and then looking
forward to you
pursue your Saint John's career that you
um dream of so much appreciate oh
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]